وعطفا على ما يجري في خان يونس ننوه الى
هذا الخبر العاجل فقد افاد مراسل الجزيره
عن ان قصفا عنيفا يستهدف في هذه الاثناء
مناطق عده في خان يونس جنوبي قطاع غزه اذا
هناك استئناف للقصف العنيف الذي تنتهجه
قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في عده مناطق في خانيونس في
متابعه للتطورات الان من شمال القطاع ينضم
الينا من مستشفى الشفاء في مدينه غزه مرسل
الجزيره اسماعيل الغول اسماعيل كذلك ربما
شمال القطاع ليس افضل حالا ما جديد
التطورات هناك وما الذي
رصدته نعم اذا ما تحدثنا عن حال شمال قطاع
غزه هي غارات عنيفه ومتواصله طوال هذا
الليل لكن دون وقوع الحمد لله حتى هذه
اللحظه اي من الاصابات والشهداء لم يصل
مجمع شفاء الطبي اي من الاصابات حتى هذه
اللحظه لكن حصيله شهداء امس كان 37 شهيدا
جل هؤلاء الشهداء الذين تم انتشالهم عقب
انسحاب قوات الاحتلال من اطراف منطقه حي
الزيتون ومن منطقه دوار انصار ومحيطها اتت
جثامين الشهداء بحاله صعبه جدا حتى
الاهالي لم يستطيعوا القاء نظره الوداع
الاخيره بسبب هذه الحاله وبالاضافه الى
ذلك وصلت جزء من الجثث متحلله بسبب الحصار
الذي استمر قرابه ست ايام في تلك المنطقه
بالتحديد منطقه جنوب غرب مدينه غزه
الواقعه في منطقه دوار انصار ومنطقه
الصفاره القطريه ومنطقه البحر هذه المناطق
التي كانت تعج باليات الاحتلال يوم امس
انسحبت والان هذه هذ هذا المكان بلا اليات
لكن اذا ما تحدثنا عن الواقع الصحي
والواقع الانساني في شمال قطاع غزه نحن
نتحدث عن واقع منهار جدا
ودون اي من المقومات الحياتيه الطبيه او
حتى المعيشيه فاذا ما تحدثنا عن المقومات
الطبيه التي يحاول الاحتلال تكرارها في
جنوب قطاع غزه باسقاط المستشفيات على
الخدمه الان نحن نتحدث عن شمال قطاع غزه
المنهار صحي دون ادويه ودون مستلزمات حتى
دون وقود لتشغيل هذه المستشفيات هي كميات
بسيطه جدا وقليله جدا تاتي طولها طوال هذه
الفتره وصلت مجمع شفاء الطبي 19000 لترا
فقط خلال الشهر الماضي وهو هذا المجمع هو
بحاجه يوميا قرابه وفق المصدره الطبيه الى
9000 لتر لتشغيل هذا المجمع فالكميه او جل
الكميه لا تكفي لتشغيل قرابه يومين لكن
القطاع الصحي لازال يحاول تدعيم وتقويم ما
تم تدميره من قوات الاحتلال سواء الاجهزه
التي دمرت او الاقسام التي دمرت فاذا ما
تحدثنا عن مستشفى الشفاء نحن نتحدث عن
محطه الاكسجين التي دمرت وقسم الحروق الذي
اصبح خارج الخدمه بالاضافه الى قسم الكلى
الذي عزز وحاول تشغيله حاولت الطواقم
الطبيه تشغيله رغم الوضع الكارثه الا انها
حاولت انقاذ حياه المرضى على الرغم من
وقوع بعض الوفيات من امراض من مرضى الكلى
بسبب عدم الغسيل المستمر في شمال قطاع غزه
اما اذا ما تحدثنا تحدثنا عن باقي
التخصصات ترميم العظام والجراحه والاعصاب
نحن نتحدث عن افتقار كبير للاطباء الذين
يعملون في هذه التخصصات وهذا ما يؤثر جليا
على حياه المرضى ويشكل خطرا كبيرا ايضا
على حياه المرضى في دداخل مجمع الشفاء
الطبي لكن مناشدات الاهالي دائما ما تكون
الى الى التسريع في عمليه والتسريع في
عمليه السفر الى الخارج لاستكمال الرحل
العلاجيه لابنائهم في ظل التخوف الكبير من
عمليات البتر للاقدام او للايدي او حتى
فقدان الحياه بسبب الاص
اجسام المصابين بسبب القصف الاسرائيلي
المستمر شكرا جزيلا لك من مستشفى الشفاء
في مدينه غزه مراسل الجزيره اسماعيل الغول